so how's everybody doing today it's cold
outside where I live it's snowing it's
disgusting I hate it but I want to take
you guys on a tour of my video
background because that's something that
I've been requested to do a lot a lot of
people ask me what's in my background
what it means to me why it's and bored
and why it's there
sometimes things are obscured by my
shoulder and they're like what is that
in the corner I must know what it is
because everything back there has a
reason for being back there and I want
to express to you guys why it's there
and I hope you enjoy this video very
much
also I'm going to talk to you guys about
a couple new blu-rays I picked up
because a lot of people wanted to know
about blu-ray updates since I made that
blu-ray collection video I'm doing a
giveaway of a digital copy of my Argo
extended edition that's going to be on
Twitter and I'll talk to you guys about
that pretty soon so I call this my
action hero corner it's got these badass
dudes in their predator or Dutch from
predator it's pretty awesome a great
looking action figure this Kirk was
given to me by my mother as a present
and I've enjoyed owning it very much
that show makes me laugh the old Star
Trek it's it's so cheesy but it's
actually kind of well written too it's
enjoyable to watch has great characters
this John McClane from die hard is
pretty awesome you can kind of tell
right there but not quite in this image
that he actually has the names of the
terrorists written on his hands and
permanent marker it's pretty detailed in
case you guys didn't know I did grow up
watching Dragonball Z it was a staple of
my childhood it was the thing that I
could not wait to do as soon as I got
home from school I would run home off
the bus immediately start watching -
Nami and I'm so glad that tsunami is
actually still on Cartoon Network they
you know they brought it back on Adult
Swim Saturday nights and I do enjoy
watching that so yeah this thing cost me
about 40 bucks because it has an absurd
amount of articulation points this Hey
Arnold little toy with Abner his Pig my
favorite show and Nick growing up I
adore hey Arnold this Princess Leia was
also a present for my mom she likes to
give me geek gifts and she pretty much
is the best mom ever and I enjoy having
a buddy gotta have a badass lady in
there because there's a lot of badass
chicks in cinema now these glasses these
Marvel glasses were also a gift
and I think they really flesh out my
background give it some more color
Nintendo 64 was a staple of my childhood
as well and Goldeneye double-oh-seven
at camp I can't even imagine how many
matches I had of multiplayer with my
friends on that course my NES as well
great to have back there
extremely nostalgic this Man of Steel
blu-ray collection was actually on sale
at Walmart for like $25 when it first
came out and the blu-ray it comes with
the 3d blu-ray and the regular blu-ray
and everything and just the the regular
blu-ray was almost the exact same price
so there's my blockbuster membership
card along with my superhero shelf
I guess geez I'm like a child I don't
care I don't really have to explain who
those people are you know who all of
them are I do like how my Batman kind of
lines up with my Dark Knight poster
though I I do very much enjoy that
aspect of that I am such a nerd I don't
care all right so here's a look at my
posters I got a Nintendo 64 poster
Empire Strikes Back Dark Knight
that is a shadows with the Empire
Nintendo 64 poster that came in my
Nintendo Power
that's jet force Gemini it came in my
strategy guide very hard to find that
poster actually I've Drive Cowboy Bebop
the movie Raiders the Lost Ark Casino
Royale inceptions Inception excuse me
not in chef inceptions is apparently the
sequel that shouldn't happen I want to
believe from the x-files
you may recognize that it's pretty cool
I don't know how long the Hunger Games
Catching Fire poster will stay there I
just like the orange theme that's kind
of created by some of my posters and it
looks nice in the background but now
we're getting into some posters that
aren't always showing up in the videos
the Avengers 1 is there but also below
is a signs poster a Minority Report
poster and just in the corner is a Close
Encounters of the Third Kind poster
that's just kind of there to block the
wall from showing up that is the Last of
Us box that was given me for free at
Best Buy and I just I love the game so
much they gave it to me it was awesome I
have my very own little xenomorph toy as
well as a Black Widow
little tiny like 2-inch figure and a
Wolverine which probably should go for
my superhero shelf I guess another Star
Wars toy a snow trooper holding this
blaster cannon
and a snowspeeder as well and if you get
kind of close in there you can actually
kind of see that there is a little dude
in there he's just chilling in there
he's having fun yeah that's his life he
sits in there that's what he does
here's my goosebumps collection a couple
old VHS tapes I love to collect older
stuff from when I was a kid
eerie Indiana series I don't know if
anyone remembers that a secret codes mm
Boca exclusively from Blockbuster that I
forgot to mention in my video
stupid me as well as a custom-made DVD
of my Indiana Jones fan film my good
buddy
drew that art for me it's about an hour
long it's kind of fun maybe I'll put it
up on the internet someday as well as
some Dragonball Z manga gotta have it
all so this is my Stephen King
collection I have a fair amount of
Stephen King as well as a shining book
in there that my buddy Pedro who I met
in Toronto sent to me thanks buddy that
was cool
my Charlie Brown collection in my Drive
book from the book that was based on the
movie or the movie that was based on the
blah blah blah blah my Nintendo 64
collection I have these custom-made
cases they're pretty cool and it's if
you can't tell I enjoy collecting things
from my childhood and it's not just
because I'm a child at heart but it
makes me feel good you know you walk
into your room and you're basically
filled and greeted with many memories
that make you happy now here's my
blu-rays I have done collection videos
before my 500th video was my complete
collection I've gotten a few more since
then I'm going to talk to you guys about
my Argo blu-ray that I got I'm going to
be given away the digital copy for free
I'll talk to you guys about that in a
second but for now here's some more
video games I have some Wii GameCube
Super Nintendo these cases were given to
me by retro game cases calm retro game
cases calm that guy is a complete badass
and he gave me such a good deal on these
cases that I feel the intense urge to be
able to give him a shout-out retro game
cases calm that guy is freaking awesome
I mean these cases are like super high
quality and they make me feel good like
I'm actually at a rental store browsing
the case when I look at my older games
and I'm able to encase them and keep
them safe from dust and discoloration
definitely
that guy out retro game cases dot-com
he's a complete badass he's awesome if
you can't tell I think he's a badass
should I say it again Metal Gear Solid
excuse me Metal Gear for NES definitely
a extremely nostalgic game for me
this guy's website retro game cases
definitely check it out he can offer you
some pretty cool deals on game cases to
be able to keep those things nice and
safe he was a cool guy it was really
nice and I was like I'm definitely gonna
make sure I mention him in this video
because he's pretty awesome so Warner
Brothers was kind enough to send me the
Argo extended edition on blu-ray this
comes out on December 3rd I suggest
picking it up it was a great movie I
really enjoyed it but this blu-ray is
pretty incredible it's got quite a bit
of awesome things and it's got of course
the blu-ray itself it has this really
cool confidential folder that has these
two posters that come for the movie one
of them is the fake sci-fi poster that's
in the movie it's pretty awesome but
like I said I am doing a giveaway of the
digital copy of this movie I don't use
it other people may enjoy it it's not
really my thing I like to pop in the
disc and actually watch it on my
television all you really got to do is
follow me on Twitter and retweet this
tweet that I made here's the picture of
it go to my Twitter which is at Chris
underscore stuckman retweet that and
follow me and in a couple days I'll pick
a random guy you just tell me where you
want me to send the code I will send you
the code and you can download it
straight from Warner Brothers it'll be
yours for free I might do that every
once in a while because I get a lot of
blu-rays and the digital copy I don't
really care about it I usually give them
to some of my friends but my friend
already had Argo so I thought hey why
not I'll do a giveaway a couple other
blu-rays I picked up you guys might be
interested in his star trek into
darkness
I actually got this for 1199 brand new I
saw this at a supermarket in Ohio it's
called giant eagle 1199 for the brand
new star trek into darkness blu-ray it
was like they did a Miss price or
something I didn't even understand what
was going on I felt like I was actually
stealing it from them it was crazy I
also picked up only God forgives on
blu-ray a very divisive movie a movie
that a lot of people were unsure of some
people thought it was a masterpiece
other people hated it I'll tell you one
thing I've liked the film more and more
as I watch it something about it keeps
making me want to see it more something
about the visual style of it just makes
me want to keep watching it I don't
understand what it is it's a strange
movie it's nowhere near conventional
narrative in anyway and it's kind of
good for that actually and lastly I
recently picked up the world's and on
blu-ray one of my favorite movies of the
year really hilarious movie completes
the unofficial Cornetto trilogy so those
are some of the blu-rays I picked up
recently as I told you Argo extended
edition digital blu-ray I'm going to be
giving that away just follow me on
twitter at chris underscore stuckman and
retweet that tweet i'll pick a random
winner you just tell me where to send
that code and the Argo extended edition
will be yours I hope you like this tour
of my background I like to do random
videos like this every once in a while I
call them passion videos you know
they're just videos that I want to make
that I don't necessarily have to make
but they're fun hopefully you guys
enjoyed it thanks as always for watching
guys and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes